and then let's get into this first story
which i think is
it's it's small but i think we got some
good news here the wall street journal
reports u.s cancels icbm test
uh a test launch amid ukraine tensions
the move follows putin's threat to
increase readiness of russia's nuclear
forces
they say the byte administration has
cancelled a routine test launch of an
air force minuteman iii missile to avoid
escalating nuclear tensions with russia
u.s officials said wednesday the air
force had planned to conduct the test
launch from vandenberg air force base in
the early hours of thursday march 3rd
and wednesday however the administration
decided to postpone the test launch amid
tensions with kremlin over ukraine so
the news that was coming out is that um
the foreign minister in in russia said
world war iii will be nuclear it will be
devastating basically
some have called it a thin thinly veiled
threat to nato you screw with us we drop
bombs
others have said it's kind of just a
truth
that it will come to nuclear war and
then he's not trying to say you know
we'll we'll blow you up
but uh i i i see this as maybe not the
most important or impactful thing in the
world but i think it shows the us is not
willing to to push to push to to bring
us to that conflict if even for just
something as small as a routine test
rightly so but what do you think do you
think there's a real prospect for uh
escalation outside of ukraine well there
is there is a danger of escalation if
you look to
what some of the politicians are
are pushing there you you look at some
of the voices and how they've been
talking about this war
and it's worrying i don't think it's
going to happen
but i do worry about some of these
voices it's interesting if you notice a
pattern right the same voices that
wanted to
uh to impose coveted mandates on
everybody else to protect themselves are
the same voices that would want to send
our sons and relatives to war to protect
themselves
yep well i'll tell you i gotta i got
some applications for the army for
everybody who's in favor of u.s
intervention by all means sign on up and
head on over and they won't [ __ ] of
course they'd rather we go they don't
want to go they'd rather we go and and
and serve their aims and their purposes
we're still i think they'd rather your
children go exactly horrifying yeah and
that's how it's always been though you
know yeah everything you're still
fighting age though
me uh i'm 35 i'm going to be 36 and 70.
still fighting age i suppose don't say
he's gonna start walking around with a
cane okay and i will i will i will brag
my resting heart rate 48. don't say
you're all right well you just got
drafted buddy good job my goodness i'm i
i've been uh i got this health app and
i've been you know blood pressure has
improved dramatically making it worse
i've been exercising well you're a super
soldier is what you're saying i'm just
i'm just like i don't want to fight in
the war but i would be the best soldier
this is i'm just it's like i feel like
it's a great accomplishment for myself
to be getting healthy you know i feel
like everybody should do that absolutely
he's going to brag about it well if the
military's watching i'm just in horrible
shape there's no sheamus sheamus feet
are so flat
ever yeah exactly i mean i can say
that's good news i'm happy they're doing
this uh because it is it's good to
de-escalate but some of the rhetoric i
mean we had the mayor of london
talk about look you know if there is a
nuclear attack on london we're ready
that kind of rhetoric is just
unnecessary i think considering what's
going on and what's going on is worrying
i mean look putin invaded a country
right nobody can countenance or can or
condone in the invasion of any country i
just find it strange that the voices
that
some of the voices that till this day
don't accept it was wrong to invade iraq
or afghanistan right are now condemning
putin's invasion of a foreign country i
seem to think that as we're invading
iraq right now it's a constant invasion
we're still there yeah it is occupation
we are occupying and invading that
country on a daily basis by being there
it's not like it happened and it
happened in the past it's happening
right now the thing is what i find
amazing with this and i i think it's
it's really interesting that we're i
believe we're in george orwell in 1984
split the world up
into uh four different um
uh uh blocks right oceana which was
landing strip one which is the uk and
then america and its sphere of influence
which includes what we call the five
eyes so australia canada new zealand the
anglo-saxon sphere the other block that
orwell used in in 1984 was east asia and
that just considered china in that area
and then he had eurasia right eurasia
was russia and europe
and then there was the disputed
territory which if you think about today
it's very accurate it was the muslim
majority lands
that are the subject of the whims of the
other three and and still disputed right
so if you look at how orwell divided the
world it's so curious to me today that
when you look at these blocks emerging
and you look at the current conflict you
can see a eurasia the russian sphere of
influence emerging you can see
post-brexit oceana emerging which is the
anglo-saxon world and you can see china
already there with east asia and you can
see that they are all fighting over the
resources in the middle east it's very
curious to see how accurate orwell's
vision of the world was i wonder if it's
a self-fulfilling prophecy like jules
verne would draw the submarine eight in
1820 or whatever well before they ever
created them and then you know art
becomes a reality submarine's prior to
that actually yeah yeah very primitive
ones in fact there were plans for
submarines drawn up as early as like the
late 1500s
yeah davinci for instance would pen like
um helicopters he would draw those well
before they were ever i wonder if orwell
created a fantasy realm that is now
being created yeah he got the date wrong
yeah 1984 we're in 2022 however i do
think it was more than um a coincidence
he kind of had a quite a strong grip on
on world affairs but he was a man
looking through a keyhole trying to see
the entirety of a ballroom yeah and so
if you look at brave new world i think
we're seeing elements of that absolutely
fahrenheit 451 yeah prophetic and a v
for vendetta even i mean there's just
yeah uh or graphic and graphic novel
yeah that's right yeah so uh graphic
novel is very very different i've not
read it but it was very different but
the where i was going with this though
is that we are unaware of how we are
perceived in oceana i'm going to use
that phrase to refer to the anglo-saxon
world today just to continue with
orwell's um kind of you know
point there we're unaware how we're
perceived so when we condem and we
should condemn russia's invasion of
ukraine what we don't realize is that
the vast majority of the rest of the
world the vast majority of humanity
are laughing at us because we're still
in iraq this you talk about earlier how
valuable it is to know what the world is
like before the internet if you know
what the world is like before the
invasion of iraq you know that it's not
normal and it's the bastardization of
truth and justice and honesty and
leadership and we've completely lost any
moral high ground to talk about this and
that's part of the problem that you know
the media is whipping up such a frenzy
over this and then i remember just two
years ago i went on a five-day hunger
strike because of the uyghur genocide in
china i remember that and the purpose
was to get a hundred thousand signatures
on a a petition because there's a
parliamentary petition if you get a
hundred thousand signatures on that
petition you force a debate in
parliament now we got that um a hundred
thousand within five days
and then it went to parliament and then
they voted unanimously
on the fact that there was a genocide in
china but it was only a symbolic vote
which is why it got through it would not
have got through if it wasn't a symbolic
vote so you've got these talking heads
like the mayor of london and others like
uh certain politicians war hawks who
were talking about
the need to impose a no-fly zone over
ukraine which would mean that we shoot
down russian jets which is an act of war
right so these idiots don't realize that
you end up declaring war in russia if
you do that those same voices were not
only quiet about the genocide in china
the wigar genocide but resisted any
effort to hold china accountable for it
yeah exactly well we had the olympics
there and we still sent our athletes
over and what were you mentioning
earlier tim with the the russians that
we were
pulling their athletes or can you
refresh me yeah so well uh several
organizations have banned russian and
belarusian athletes from competing like
iron man did it yeah and uh there's a
there's a couple others triathlons the
spirit of the olympics is that even if
you're at war you send your best
athletes you let them pass through your
territory unhindered and then they all
compete because it's the spirit of human
competition it's beyond warfare i just
find it so out of touch and then there
there are these calls look again i'm
going to have to re-emphasize every time
i say something on this topic but again
putin should not have gone into ukraine
but he's not hitler and there are these
people saying he's the new hitler when
you've got an active genocide going on
in china and the worst part of this is
when you talk about hitler and nazism in
ukraine in 2014 there was a change of
regime that we in the west encouraged
the maidan uprising that putin would
call a coup now whatever word you want
to use there was regime change that we
we meaning our intelligence agencies
backed with full throttle wholeheartedly
we back that regime change because the
government in ukraine was pro-russia it
pulled out of the affiliation with the
eu and we didn't like that we wanted it
to be pro-west so we backed that regime
changing who we bring to power
nazis actual nazis who do you think
zolensky or no no he's not a nazi he's
jewish but the you've got this thing
called the azov brigade yeah yeah yeah
the battalion right
as of battalion they are an armed nazi
but now the word nazi the problem is
it's been so overused today that nobody
really believes the word
nazi or racist when it actually deserves
to be used but let's just be very clear
these guys have uh they are
swastika-raising actual neo-nazis and i
mean that in the literal sense of the
word and even the word literal is no
longer literally yeah that's true you've
got to bring the word figure it's
literally been changed it means
something else we talked about this with
lauren southern as well it is
unbelievable right and they are they are
formally incorporated
into the ukrainian national guard we
funded them by the way we when i say we
funded them actually sent them money
uh we trained them we funded them uh
canada the us and the uk were involved
in backing this uh battalion and then
they were incorporated into the
ukrainian national guard and then once
uh putin attacked
the ukrainian national guard from their
official and formal and verified twitter
account
posted a video
bragging that this was an azov fighter
dipping bullets in pig's lard saying
that he was going to go and find the
muslims it's like that uh that that
urban legend that apocryphal story are
you familiar
there's always there there's a an
american general in in the middle east
you know uh killed a bunch of islam yeah
soldiers yeah and then but kept one
alive
and put pig's blood on the corpses and
said go tell everyone what we did but
it's not i believe that story is not
true yeah i i don't think but this is of
this one it's a video right right and
the thing is i'm saying it's probably he
probably saw that meme story on the
internet and maybe but the thing is put
let's let's put aside the emotional um
reaction that some people may have to
that video right and consider it
strategically
the mistake historically that
chamberlain made was to appease nazism
in europe in the belief that they could
be of use to defeat the soviet union
so we know how that ended what you've
got at the moment is you've got a nazi
battalion as formally incorporated into
the ukrainian army in their military
and neo-nazis from around the world are
now traveling there to train with them
they are armed and they are part of the
ukrainian armed forces my question is if
if they win or if ukraine is split to
east and west and they've got the river
in the middle if putin takes from the
upper river putin takes eastern ukraine
and the ukrainian regime that's there
currently keeps the western part the
nazis that are serving in their national
guard in their army who are pretty much
the most powerful faction in terms of
grassroots uh mobilization i mean guys
there are videos of children's summer
camps in ukraine making nazi salutes
there's nazi summer camps they've had
mass rallies these are actual proper
organized nazis with swastikas with
insignia and everything now
imagine in whichever part they end up
maintaining they are now the government
so you've got an actual nazi government
that we found sounds a lot like isis
yeah sounds like an easy target why how
did al qaeda get created
the cia were funding what they the
mujahideen that's right right to defeat
the soviets now in if it's not okay to
they don't learn do that no
it's intentional they did learn and they
they said
here's the thing they do study history
it's just that world war ii is the only
thing that ever happened in all of
history so anytime anything happens we
we have to say that guy is hitler and so
like you said pointing to uh putin and
going that guy's hitler i mean i don't
know he's a tyrannical leader over
russia and now he's imposing himself on
ukrainians is there anyone in history
who that just sounds like a little bit
more like besides hitler yeah i mean
he's an illiberal autocrat is the word
to describe illiberal illiberal autocrat
right he's a dictator who's not he's not
really keen on elections but he's not
hitler there's actual nazis we're
funding and backing this sounds like the
overthrow of the shah and iran we put
the ayatollah in power and it was like a
radical well from what i've learned and
maybe you can enlighten me radical
islamic regime in power because we
wanted it to fight and dis destabilize
the region but then it ended up
destabilizing the whole world
from my perspective more modern it's
it's syria that was 79. it's the same
and some people some people say look
your country's been invaded everyone
should fight we don't care if they're
nazis and my point is
if they're look every country has racist
and every country has nazis and every
country has jihadist extremists but if
you organize them into a formal
battalion that's the equivalent so the
analogy is false there with saying every
country has racists the equivalent
analogy is the us armed force is having
a formal kkk battalion with kkk flags as
part of the army
that's the analogy right it's shocking
if the us did that if the uk did that
people will be upping arms but we're
funding it in ukraine and
how come uh many of these woke
youtubers and personalities who have no
problem in fact monetize
attacking nazis are now very much in
favor of our support of these groups in
ukraine right so listen like uh
promoting a white man at work is deemed
racist but literally funding an actual
nazi armed battalion
is is fine the enemy of my enemy is my
friend so they say i'm not a fan of that
idea if they're gonna say that then i'm
gonna hold them to their word and say so
why is it wrong to fund isis in syria
and go and join them we've got we've got
uk media calling for british citizen
volunteers to go and join the foreign
legion in ukraine and join these people
so hang on a minute so when young muslim
men went to join isis in syria that's
terrorism but you can go and join a nazi
brigade in ukraine it's because public
perception
they look isis somehow managed to get i
think the famous image was like a
detroit plumbing company pickup truck in
syria or whatever and everyone's like
how did they get this yeah how did how
how were what these weapons being given
to many of these rebel groups ultimately
then you know becoming isis and it's
because
i think it's fair to say correct me if
i'm wrong the u.s wants to dece if the
u.s wants to destabilize a region they
provide material support to insurgent
groups or extremist groups who then
create problems well and so then that
begs the question what's going on in
ukraine really like why have we been
funding
armed nazi battalions who have now been
incorporated into the uh ukrainian
regime what's going on i i feel like
it's it wouldn't be out of the question
and far be it for me i'm not an expert
um
i think it's possible the country splits
in half yeah so i spent some time uh
during my dan i was in i went to ukraine
and i and i got to meet people
and uh talk to them everybody down there
was pro-eu they said getting access to
the schengen zone getting access to the
european union means a better economy
and russia wants them to join the the
trade federation which is similar but
much weaker and smaller and it was a bad
deal for ukrainians not to mention a lot
of people i talked to said honestly
we're scared of what russia would do if
they're given power over us because we
saw what happened last time they had
power over us holla damore so there many
of these people especially in kiev were
very much like rather be with europe
sorry it seems like the us has been
using influence tactics bribery
manipulation like we saw with joe biden
if you don't if you don't fire the
prosecutor you don't get the billion
dollar guaranteed loans which is is
criminal and he admitted to it uh it was
influenced tactics but the bribes the
cash the money it works putin didn't
have that apparently they didn't care
enough but like you mentioned the regime
change in 2014 the president yanukovych
was effectively ousted fled the country
went to russia the new government comes
in very pro-west so russia loses because
of that protest and now it seems his
only option it seems to be a last resort
physical invasion well why why was why
was that so important to him after he
lost is is really interesting
most of germany's gas comes through
ukraine yeah and that's why he was
building nordstrom 2 to go through the
black sea to bypass because if you think
about it
uh sorry the baltic sea yeah if you
think about it he had the access through
ukraine he loses that
and so he tries to build north stream
two to go straight to germany that gets
thwarted
now he's got a problem by trump exactly
right interesting right right now he's
got a problem that he he's lost he's
lost the gas going through ukraine
because the regime's changed he can't
build it through the sea
but he need but he but he's got he's the
second largest oil producer in the world
now if you want to understand you know
in terms of if americans want to want to
understand how that feels
when ukraine was lost
as in putin lost ukraine it went into
the american sphere of influence
um you end up with calls for it to join
nato
and not from 1997 the expansion of of
nato eastwards has incorporated most of
those countries but ukraine is right on
the border with russia so if you go back
to the cuban missile crisis and you
remember what it felt like for kennedy
to have those missiles pointed out
america from from cuba just 100 or so
miles away
putin's got to a point where saying
you're building bases on my border
you're asking for nato membership and
this is my backyard
why could ukraine not have stayed stayed
neutral that's the geopolitical conflict
that's going on i think that's part of
it but latvia and estonia are nato
members and they and they're on the
border
with russia according to scott horton
who's just on kennedy nation he was
saying that it was condoleezza rice that
got them into nato and put long-range
tomahawk missile nuclear yeah but they
didn't have the gas going through them
exactly so i this you know one of the
things i've been saying is
there's the belief that um a lot of
people have a lot of people believe the
conspiracy theory vladimir putin is
fighting klaus schwab in the world
economic forum in the new world order
you had that um that ukrainian member of
parliament who said that we're fighting
for a new world order and so there are
people who believe that there's this
great global battle and putin is defying
it and i'm like putin just wants to make
sure he's getting the proper resources
in exchange for the oil he produces so
that he can fund his country i wonder do
you think he has a some sort of issue
with the world economic forum and
he was on their website he was a member
so i i don't know if i don't know if
that holds up because he was a member
himself and they've just taken his
profile off oh wow switzerland they just
removed him switzerland is no longer
neutral they finally declared
non-neutrality in a war for the first
time i've ever seen and that's what the
bank of international settlements is
which is the central bank of central
banks yeah well what what i can say is
that when you cancel russia from swift
and visa and mastercard what you are
doing is precipitating
the the the need for
um for for russia to develop its own
financial system now when you when you
kick russia out of that uh that could
lead to a run on russian banks and if
there's a run on russian banks if
germany as it is is dependent on russian
gas that will have a knock-on effect on
germany's economy and you could end up
with weimar style uh hyperinflation uh
that could lead to in russia uh in but
not just russia outside of russia
because germany relies on russian gas so
energy prices spike we're already seeing
that and that's how much for gas out
here yeah yeah so the huge spike in
energy prices has an open effect to the
point where stagflation uh really pretty
much ends up destroying uh the currency
so it could end up being used regardless
of whether it's planned or not i tend
not to go into intentions i just look at
reality and describe it and say this is
what's happening so you could end up
with a scenario where because of
stagflation uh the dollar as a global
reserve currency comes under intense
pressure and it's that moment that is
used as an opportunity to switch over to
central banking digital currencies
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you